we're learning new details in the case
of a missing Wisconsin woman whose
disappearance prompted a massive search
yoga student Kelly Dwyer vanished in
2013 detectives learned she was last
seen on a date than surveillance images
revealed vital new clues for
investigators Peter Van Sant reports on
the search for Dwyer like the rest of
Milwaukee Assistant District Attorney
Sarah hill found Kelly Dwyers sudden
disappearance baffling her social media
goes dead her debit card goes dead it's
like she just isn't anymore 27 year old
Kelly worked as a nanny and as a
salesperson in an athletic clothing
store I think that people saw those
images and realized this could be my
daughter
this could be my best friend Kathryn
Spano then a detective with the
Milwaukee Police Department learned that
Kelly was last seen on a date with 38
year old Chris Sacco
he was smart yet a nice car a beautiful
condo down on the east side in fact it
was at that condo where police trace
Kelly's final steps as she and Chris
arrived back from their night out
detective Tammy Tramel McClain says the
building's cameras would provide another
clue by what is not seen she don't come
out of the building Kelly is never seen
leaving the next morning as Saco claimed
at this point we're thinking the worst
and for you the worst is what that she's
deceased
Peter Vansant joins us now Peter good
morning so was Kelly's body ever found
it was found a fellow about 19 months
later is out on a hike in some remote
woods he sees a glint of light goes to
check it out it's a human skull there
were just skeletal remains though and
from those remains they weren't able to
determine a cause of death you were
telling us Peter there 28 cameras around
that building had a police explain they
never saw her good question the cameras
that were in the garage where Chris Saco
the boyfriend parked his car were motion
activated
it's one of those frustrating moments
those of us who have motion activated
cameras you see him at the trunk of the
car but you don't see him get to the
trunk of the car
authorities later believe because they
travel golf bag is missing that her body
was placed inside that and taken to the
car but this is a circumstantial case
there was no video of that fact so we'll
find out what happened to mr. Socko mr.
Socko and Kelly Dwyer yeah very much and
you can see Peters report the
disappearance of Kelly Dwyer tomorrow at
10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS